we family or you know we're not Gang
Related we call the bottom because just
the name of the neighborhood we from the
bottom we automatic Bottom bar so we
could go anywhere but Bloods Crips stuff
like that they can't go everywhere
because they limit you know we ain't
Limited because we number one we go
anywhere
yeah
[Music]
but y'all up to man yeah you know
[__]
you got my OG here and then you got my
young G here there you go
both my OG both your OG's huh yeah
Ricardo man let me start where you put
you on a hot seat man
who who are these uh who are these men
sitting next to you man
America mother wanted
not this big on
in this big um this is my blood on right
here though this um
know what I'm saying
and I always heard this uncle right here
bounce even the most wild thing you know
what I'm saying Wild Things Wild Thing
yeah that's how I heard about you man
did you hear when you were locked up did
you hear that Don got out
oh yeah be done in all my loogie work
that's who did all my league work after
he left with Larry Hoover started doing
my legal work leader these are the GDs
but done every hey Don when you come
visit Don Don told me cut cut that food
is though man the man want to come see
you and going on because I listened to
him I said I don't listen to him I ain't
never been scared of nobody but this
dude here got a love enlarge it that
makes you want to hear what he say you
know I'm saying he he quiet but that's
something we're gonna stand behind
everything he's sick
he gonna stand with you and anything you
get into but
when you tell you something he's going
to tell you what's right
and that's why I love him he ain't
cutting no corners he ain't gonna always
tell me what I want to hear but he gonna
tell me what's right
how about you man what uh did you think
you was gonna see bam did you think he
was gonna get out oh yeah I Really Gonna
Get Out
what was the first thing you thought
when you seen him
[__] he was at home
that's okay I could though yeah we all
made it back home
what was it like for you the first time
you seen the bottoms after you after you
was gone for so long [__] up
because everything was gone
it ain't the bottom no more really you
know well I mean from living you know me
but they're still home though yeah I
remember you were saying that last night
yeah you stay at home but I mean they'll
change it but that's still our home
though yeah we always gonna be bottom
you can't take that out of us what is
the bottoms to you what's the bottom
steel home
Robert gonna be home regard what they do
down there it's still home
I remember everything that was down
there can you describe it look the
bottom yeah we have to describe what
what part you want me to describe take
me through it man take me through take
me through you know Spanish street
fantas street you know like uh late late
you know 1988 tell me what I would see
down there like what was the energy like
everything
and eight eight but most everything was
still there maybe
I'll go back to the to the 70s on
Louisiana coming out in front of the
street
when I live coming up
all it took
on Lamb on the Block
how we live and what we did and
everything how do you how how do you
remember the bottoms man like back then
the the 80s
the way I was coming up as a generation
under him man going on but I listened to
the old heads and I watched the way they
regulated they didn't go for nothing
they wasn't sure change or nothing and
that made me feel like I I deserve to
say it right ain't nobody gonna treat me
no any kind of way cause I Come From The
Bottom I stand up and I'm gonna be a man
and I'm gonna go buy these coats they
had certain code that was already in
steel that's why I like it in a new
generation the new generation Ricardo
and the Dude is coming up there ain't no
punks but they ain't going for nothing
but yet still they means they can think
and when you got to thank us you can
achieve something you got dumb as you
can't achieve nothing
and that's the same thing I took what he
taught me and I took it a step further
and prayerfully
Carter will take what we know and he'll
take it a step further but he's the Next
Generation he our Legacy y'all we got
um you know a lot of people told me
about like the ethics and and the code
of the bottoms how you take care of each
other yeah what's that mean to you
everything
[__] that's why I came up
look when I got well you know banned
with I've been able to live we were
staying on Travis Street and stuff like
that and you know but I just growed up
to do good I mean done good that being
done for the whole Hood
and then we go outside the hood we help
peoples and all that type of [__] too
yeah I mean yeah we ain't got to be
ready for the bottom all you do just be
real that's it you don't have to be from
the bottom you know for somebody to do
something for you
because a lot of people I heard wanted
to be down there huh like a lot of
people always wanted to come down there
like that was the place to be yeah but
back then it was he couldn't come let's
you don't have to know somebody but uh
over the years it changed as long as
they're coming down and just do you and
going back to them starting on [__] or
nothing like that you all right yeah
yeah yeah we get a pass like that yeah
yeah when you [__] up you get served
yeah down there yeah yeah but you messed
up you get served yeah because you're
disrespect enough that's our home yeah
this ain't the neighborhood you go to
it's gonna be the same time yeah yeah
did you go to Cedar Grove if you go over
there and mess up they gonna serve
because that's their neighborhood but
was the bottoms different
we no more
always been that way yep
it'll be number one we go anywhere
yeah see we're not we we family or you
know we're not gang related
we call the bottom because just the name
of the neighborhood we from the bottom
so we automatic Bottom Boys
that's how they work but we could go
anywhere but Bloods Crips stuff like
that
you know we ain't Limited
you know real reason we go anywhere one
of the Bloods and the Crips start
showing up around Shreveport one team
came from California when they ran
California
back in 80 something back again wasn't
there a
what happened uh wasn't there a time
when when some Crips came crack came for
the bottoms and we served them too what
happened that night we just had a little
shootout
but they came why they felt that they
could take the money or what no but they
were tripping they didn't really know
what we were going to do but they got
served do you guys remember what that
was over
no some [__] happened up there with some
other homeboys and [__] okay well that's
all we needed to know though yeah yeah
we met with our people so
you get served yeah they wouldn't happen
about two months and all that type of
[__]
we went on a hunt
yeah they they surrendered they
surrendered yeah that happened we made
them call it a trip yeah quick quick
dude jumped out and seen quick seeing
how little quick was and the guys sit
there and talk crazy stuff to quick and
doom sit there and said and then so
quick said no no everybody get back
they've been down there you know just
you know just having fun with us and
[__] too before all that happened though
we were cool with them you know through
the city and [__] though but when they
did mess with our people that's what we
do yeah yeah we gotta defend your own
people don't
I'm about to get hurt now you know what
I heard I mean you correct me if I'm
wrong but that you know if something
went down there if there was vines on
the bottoms it was only because you
people were protecting their own it
wasn't it wasn't really violence on each
other no well we have fights and [__]
like me and Bam they have fight before
you and band fought three days
before hey come on tell me about that
we've got tripping you know drinking
having fun
I'm going to be three days what would
they say we're on the big one because we
thought that we drunk January
again so we just start again so for
three days y'all we'll help so hang on
hang on so yeah just hang on him so so
for three days three days so y'all be
fought today and then we stopped in
tomorrow
he was in the mediating it wasn't
because if he tell me something that's
it that's law yeah and he was
intermediated for somebody else and I
didn't I didn't cut for it and I said
don't tell me nothing about that no Elmo
and once I say don't tell me nothing
about something that means that's the
end of it so then he kept telling me so
going on and we start fighting but I was
swinging hit him in the shoulder and he
wouldn't even hit me he hit me on on the
shoulder and knocked me halfway called
the street
but finally his mama called us both in
there said listen y'all got them babies
them babies confused they don't know
what to do [__] they love both of y'all
you know good and well if somebody come
down there and touch every one of y'all
y'all are killing dead so y'all cut this
mess off y'all drink this gin and y'all
go out there and y'all let them babies
know that y'all are made up yes ma'am
that's what we do and somebody Mama tell
us something that's it tell me about
that tell me about women in the bottoms
man those are matriarchs man we did what
they say and we understood to understand
if me and him get into it miss Helen B
tell me something I don't care about
nothing that's lost
I listen to my mama
holy judge nobody
oh my mama listen to my mama
and she said something I listen to
anybody else
they don't tell me she
I just hear them say [__] but I caught
somebody in the cold room everything
don't mean [__] to me um they're gonna
do a lock me up I'm gonna get out again
[__] it don't mean nothing to me but
don't nobody telling that but my mama
well
what was you guys say Carter I said
that's the difference between the
generation nowadays like you say you
were older than especially like them
these OG they say something in this law
you know you got a lot of [__] bro they
ain't got no OG then especially like
these [__] they real in the game you
know what I'm saying they ain't got no
like yeah they gonna respect it they
ain't you know what I'm saying they try
to get their own strike so they just
like you know I'm saying that's where
they crash it you know I'm saying they
ain't got no respect man ain't nobody
learning that's how they and that's what
it is like ain't nobody ain't no law
being laid down they side you know I'm
saying I had these dudes for example so
that's why I always been different and
stood out you know what I'm saying
because like he say man oh to say
something I ain't saying that's loud you
know what I'm saying respect things not
respect the older people that way I came
up
[Music]
when you get your kids or whatever you
do the same thing
you know what I mean when they have to
be respectable to the man and all that
type of [__] too though yeah
why are you gonna put it that's the
thing about investing in people's life
duh
would not just I mean this dude here
if your car is broke you're gonna get it
fixed
if your folks ain't got nothing to eat
he gonna make sure you got something to
eat if you're in a fight he gonna go to
fight with you so when he says something
it means something not because she was
scared of him because he didn't showed
you that he invested in your life that's
why people love him the way he was
because he never cared about that stuff
he was always riding the boys sometimes
if you're lucky you'll get a big homie
that's all he's a two out of three
but when you get a homie that's a four
out of four
you you got them all the way around the
boat he'll fight with you you're gonna
help you with your finances you're gonna
feed your family and if your car broke
you're gonna get under there with you
and then you can't lose with no dude
like that you're gonna go to war with
that dude every time
you're saying it don't matter it don't
matter about nothing you willing to die
with that dude but not because you
scared of him because of the love that
he showed you you know I grew up man he
was the dudes I seen every day that's
how they acted with each other you know
I'm saying everybody you know what I'm
saying like he said
four out of four you know what I'm
saying the people that my dad hung
around they kept around you know I'm
saying like that's why like he said he
was concerned about the people that I
hang around because it's like they don't
see it like that yeah you don't see that
different character generation different
like he said four out of four with each
other you know what I'm saying you can
call them for anything like financially
you know I'm saying on some real [__]
like you know I'm saying yeah I'm saying
do you see that down like what do you
see about like what's going on on the
streets today I just see a bunch of
[__] yeah
welcome
all they don't just kill one another
they don't when we came up you know we
we fight you know we wouldn't just kill
one though but that's all they do now
they ain't gonna fight nothing now
everybody want to win so all for the win
they do drive-bys and all that type of
[__] too ain't no good right there
I don't care you don't you don't really
know all your peoples now you know I
mean because over the year Well by
saying me I don't know all my people you
know because I've been gone I know the
one that I left here and they had kids
and their kids I had kids and you know
stuff like that so that's why I just try
you know stay low keep up so I won't
mess my own people too
what the children is caught up with is
they to follow the wrong example they
rap in the example that they followed
not only that but they following some of
these dudes who never wore the rose to
the spot the hills if they hadn't swept
us out the way because we had more
aptitude so now when they swept us out
the way people who would never would
have been rise up to that spot
now they they they they need an example
they going on so you think that like the
culture of the streets today or what's
going on in Shreveport today
is a is a product you could say it's
really going on in so many cities a
product of mass incarceration and so
many that's exactly they swept us out
the way and we got all the youngsters
they grew up without them
yeah suckers teaching them yes these
dudes for us to be that's why I get mad
about Society for y'all to be angry they
lit dudes for being who they are they
followed the example that was giving
them y'all square up the good examples
out of the way and now y'all mad at them
because y'all allowed these good
examples now we back out here give us a
chance to work with these dudes and
going on if we sit here and say hey
instead of giving this dude 20 years
let's let's work with him yep give him
five years and let's work with this and
going on give us a chance to try to fix
what y'all broke but don't sit here and
tell us y'all done broke the system and
then y'all gonna throw our peoples away
for 30 and 40 years then you want us to
be happy with that how can I feel happy
when I I just lost two or three little
young homies to the penetration for 30
or 40 years and I pull to sleep good at
night system ain't broken
what happened man you caught a flat
foreign
[Laughter]
you good huh oh yeah we good what do you
think that is we were talking a little
bit about you know kind of kind of kind
of like what we were saying before about
what's going on right now with these
folks and that there's no real good Role
Models giving like a uh a moral example
of having a moral code
I mean from what I heard y'all could go
wherever you guys wanted in this city
that you guys had the respect of
everybody
like you you guys could do what you want
and and and for whatever reason you know
you could say you people feared you
people weren't gonna come down to the
bottoms and act a fool or like take
advantage of nobody nobody's gonna come
down there and do it right and and I
guess my question is there was a there
had to be a fear since there there had
to be a level of strength and power in
the bottoms that was unlike anything
else my question is I I know for me
right like I got a family if you
protecting your family there's nothing
more you had to put both of them
together remember I don't mean to cut
y'all apologize but you have to put
fierceness with fairness people always
understood that we fair you come down
there in the bottom you don't tell you
but no nothing happened to you you come
down the bottom and tell your butt and
whatever happened you brought it up for
yourself we was fair and everything we
did all I did we failed so any fairness
in in fierceness came if you you
violated this thing that we gave you
which was founded so if you come down
there and you do some crazy stuff and
you violate our code or whatever then it
happened that's even if you do it in
your own neighborhood if you ride around
here with yourself hanging all off
around children and going on and we hear
about it that we want to talk to the men
in your neighborhood that run in your
neighborhood watch this dude running
around with himself around children
if you can't explain that to us then you
open
I mean
it was just uh I think it was a group of
people man that was willing to go as far
as it as far as it needs to go you know
what I'm saying to get [__] straight uh
for the right reason
you know what I'm saying like most of
most of our friends were when I went to
school most of my friends parents used
to tell them you know what I'm saying
y'all better not go down in that bottom
but the thing was
it was a misconception like you said
once you got there it was totally
different than what they was told it was
hard for you to stay the [__] away from
down there why would a person want to be
in that environment if it was so [__]
up
right so I think that the people that
was able to if you know people believe
anything they see on TV just just like
you for instance no you can't tell them
[__] that you not shiny or that
you not the punish you know what I'm
saying so we take that [__] bro and we
run with it the wrong way you know what
I'm saying we was just like I said a
group of dudes they were willing to
stand up for the right thing and each
other and yeah we didn't file for
anything you know what I'm saying and we
was one of them we was a group of people
that was willing to stand up against the
police we respect your job but at the
end of the day you still a man you know
what they mean you bleed just like we
bleed you know what I'm saying you got a
group of people that's willing to go all
the way with you we got a group of
people that's willing to go all the way
with us you know what I'm saying but and
y'all know we right
the thing with that whole neighborhood
we were just talking the other day man
they knew that the world was changing
and they knew that
in the streets we was evolved we was
always at the top of our game So
eventually these dudes would bring my
mind was gonna change they was going to
buy the land that we trying to get
you know what I'm saying they knew that
[__] so it was a race for time if we
don't move now they won't end up buying
[__] and it's gonna push out a plan
further back
dude and went through what they went
through you came in the picture now we
write back able to put back into the
community that they just now starting to
build right we would have done way
[__] more they done nothing the whole
time that they've been gone we would
have done a whole lot more they know
that
just like the dudes they got the [__]
up agenda that dudes that running for uh
office
um trying to run for these office man so
they can get next to that money and that
power and manipulate that [__] they
trying to get on board with us for the
wrong reasons they talking about bam
talking about prison reform they talking
about locking the officers up like but
I'm saying we want to find out what the
[__] they like to do and get them
interested in that it's enough of them
in jail so our plan and they plan still
going that way
they got the money and the power all we
got is the [__] plan we didn't turn
down people yeah and see that's what
that's why the [__] film come in and
play it because we started now
yeah we starting to turn down
[__] they got a [__] up
agenda like at the end of the day we
don't give a [__] about the money the
none of that [__] man our plan is to get
our people with the right frame of mind
man so that we can continue building the
community instead of tearing them up for
the down man you know what I'm saying
totally against a plan
they want to put [__] in jail
that's why all the money the prison
system you know what I'm saying and we
know that
and um
they did what they did man and they
still hadn't put nothing back into their
community and here we go again
they throwing up some apartments but we
still got a whole nother agenda that
goes against their agenda you know what
I'm saying yeah
but we gonna move with it man and if we
you know what I'm saying if this [__]
cause a problem or something you know
what I'm saying for us doing the right
thing we willing to take that
simple as that bro
we ain't got nothing to lose
for real
and there's a power in that yeah hell
yeah simple as that man yeah that whole
[__] was the flow we do it
that's it yeah
I say man they got the money the power
and the resources we just got the right
plan
because we know the people you know what
I'm saying at the end of the day when
they running for office man the only
thing that'll get them in office it to
me honestly
if they get to know the people in the
struggle you know what I'm saying so it
takes somebody to come from that
struggle man you know what I'm saying to
run for office but we ain't gonna do
that because we know once we get to that
to that level they're gonna set your
Glover your ass you know what I'm saying
they're gonna do everything they gotta
do
to get you out of there man for real
because you feel like your home got
stolen from you yeah it was taken yeah
you took it simple as that it was taken
even though we didn't own it to call it
it was it was our home you know what I'm
saying but we didn't we didn't own the
paperwork side of it you know what I'm
saying but like I say they knew our
minds was evolving into that [__] they
knew it you know what I'm saying
yeah
didn't know they couldn't take it with
us out there
say that again
then it came in
yeah that's how it happened
on the physical side it would have been
nasty because we were willing that you
had a group of people that was willing
to
that was willing to die behind you know
what I'm saying all that they had what
they call was theirs you know what I'm
saying
and they knew that [__] which is like
what happened when the Crips tried to
take it they won't try to take it we
just had a misunderstanding and you
could come down here you know do a
little survey thing but uh
he didn't know what he was getting into
yeah his homeboy called quick out
and he looked at our skin and quick
walls yeah
we got through with him quick heated
Mary Webb but the bottom of his feet and
he couldn't accept that loss and he went
up that line beat up by a bunch of
people down in the bottom hey what
happened to I I heard a story about you
man about uh I believe that you see how
he looked over I mean he didn't have the
right lawyer and so you done slapped him
and you got a different lawyer yeah
that's when they told me the lawyer told
me said he he give me five years if I
agree to the stuff that they had against
goat and big Don so if I agree to that I
get five years and I tried to slap him
and they grabbed me wrestled me down and
they every time I see my lawyer from
that point on I had to have cups on me
told me he said hey man you need to get
rid of the lawyer that's the lawyer with
mustache Elton Richard yeah and they
they took me they had gave me a hearing
on it and the other richer said what I
told you your honor I told you these
guys here they're a different breed they
gonna stick together I asked you for
half of the money up front
he said but my he's my client I got to
bring this deal to him a five-year deals
offered to him and I had to bring it to
him and going on he said but of course
he said he said but he refused it but
I'm waiting to go all the way trial with
him if he wouldn't do this going on I
said yeah man and he said well okay well
this is the situation and you know he
said well he we gonna let him return you
as a lawyer but I said yeah man I said
this dude he said no he wasn't selling
you out he was trying if a deal was
offered to you he had to I thought you
gonna tell me that not only you didn't
just ask me to
to help out to five years but you had
many copper after five years to lie on
on two of my homeboys you're saying you
you telling me y'all got stuff that
y'all want me to say and going on y'all
lost y'all remember that man so I said
so do that mean that I can see my life
without handcuffed now and then he said
it's up to your lawyer in my life he
said yeah and so I started going down
there without a handcuff but the first
couple of months after me trying to slap
him
bill
and that's when go go talk about that
early when me and you talking you know
remember man you had the slap Fest in in
the jail when I told you I said I said
go go they never been to jail before
this Library man just be cool
you thought God was talking on you yeah
members go told you go to it yeah I told
him I said listen man don't think too
man listen man I said done listen man I
love you I don't I said that damn booger
ain't never been here
[Laughter]
and then definitely go come over there
and said listen man I ain't never been
in jail but I'm a bottom boy that's what
I'm he's still strong yeah I only met
positive for that he did you you knew
you knew go wasn't gonna say nothing
yeah that should change the game out
here in the streets but yeah because
y'all was gone yeah but when when dudes
took the stand dudes from the bottom
took the stand with us having the power
and the respect that we had induced from
the bottom to the stands it made the
whole city
and it was like okay
like you know what I'm saying
anything we did we said we set up we set
a stage whether it was for the good or
whether they said it was for the bad
you know what I'm saying people always
ran with it but when they snatched on us
that's [__] up everything
you say that again let's see when they
sneezed the roof that's [__] up
everything they took us off the street
so now everything just wide open well
ain't no more control you know through
the city no more so everybody you know
boys that's the first thing I noticed
though when y'all going and love was
gone I was like
it wasn't this thing was able to sniff
thing came through
on you know goat them in the people that
he [__] with
yeah the one on this island side where
we in the well they had one where my
nephew one one head of the partner you
know he was on the weak side
we don't feed them I say them two times
we're getting killed you know I mean but
he was the one that turned
[__] like that
when they started stitching that killed
everything
everybody started snitching all over the
city
yeah
you could do a friend all that type of
[__] oh yeah they came over slower
they were saying stuff like come on
Richard they got us now I'm here
yeah man anything about this generation
like back then I like hearing from their
generation of niggles the wrecked they
gonna say you can serve you know there's
anything to come back around like it's
all grave you gonna get in the streets
like that back then like like now
that's one of the things too that I
worry about a lot too you know what I'm
saying with like little dudes that I
know in the streets that be doing a
thing man I'd be talking to them when
they come up there and I'd be like man
you just don't understand the US they're
stacked up against you but then I had to
think they do understand uh they stacked
up against them because in their mind
they already know what they're gonna do
when the [__] hit the fans
that already yeah yeah if you got a car
full of dudes man I'm talking about
somebody if four of them got guns three
of them gonna tell it and guess what
those same three or kill something cold
blood yeah until it no for real
generation
I was telling somebody I said man to
tell you something you you this what you
got to understand about life man every
[__] uh uh generation got his own set
of rules and what they call real yeah
just like when we was coming up
too fast you know what I'm saying y'all
crazy and and and it went just like that
you know what I'm saying every
generation got his own set of rules in
place of what they call real they call
us stupid for not telling it yeah you
know what I'm saying but that's just
what it is man you gotta understand when
you playing the game
what the rules is in that game now you
know what I'm saying they gonna tell it
that's a part of it I said when you get
out the game man you got to stay out we
are out the game cause we got our sauce
right now we
now we can't win they gonna if you go
shoot one of them then you're gonna go
to jail
so I mean because that's against our
code I got shy instead when I got shot
this bathroom do my own thing it looked
the same when you when when you got shot
you just kept it to yourself well the
police came and talked about them I
don't know something I already lose
something yeah
I'm gonna take care of my part myself
yeah so that's how we lived we ain't
gonna sniff them and I mean we could
save our own people and and what would
you say to Rick man like what would you
say to Rick what what advice would you
give him right now he called Ricardo
Rick yeah Carter [__] do the same thing
I did do what you supposed to do stand
up like a man
I learned one thing I did 25 years eight
months
let's do like a year to me
because I came back home
you know what I mean it's all in the
past
everybody said God Bless America he
blessed me to come back home
I'm happy what did your time in prison
what what did that how that sounds good
how so [__] everything
I had my own sale
I was head all in the unit I run the
unit and all this [__] and and I did 25
years they never had a shot
I never had a what shot you know right
up
I ran the TVs and holy [__] how did you
how did you get to that place
from being me
oh well I know we live in the face so
you know they kind of University yeah
I'm from Louisiana
you want sweet pole Louisiana
I'm gonna get a TV
don't we don't get no TV they're gonna
lock the damn thing down
I'm gonna get a TV I'm gonna get a
single sale
all this [__] I mean
explain like how do you get that thing
yeah for who I am
what I do
see it's with I think with us man it's
like just like how you gravitated
towards me I think it's more of our the
personality is so [__] okay
how you carry yourself yeah I'm going to
press when I was in prison but I've been
trying to get to know nobody
I want to come here and do my time and
come back home
for less people you know in jail better
what was your sentence 30 years yeah
yeah the less you know the better for
you the more people you know the more
trouble you get into
so I stay away from all that type of
[__]
people got want to get to know me before
they heard of you know about me because
I heard about you out on the streets
yeah well I'm on bottom boys just that
bottom up so when you get like was that
the same for you bam you get you get
locked up people knew who you were From
The Bottom Boys yeah they did and all
that
Incorporated they said they was it was
they was hoping that we win our cash
because they've never seen that many
people stick together at trial
and they was hoping that we win because
we would have broke the feds we would
have been able to uh because they've
never seen that many people go to trial
and stick together if our own homeboy
wouldn't touch it
would that be somebody from the bottom
to testify or for the beginners
no that wasn't gonna happen outside
outside he'll see no they testify
against us our own homeboys that's how
they got us
if you want to hang with us every day in
the street know what we do but the same
one testify against us but they didn't
testified to they didn't Testify the
facts
about the prosecutors wanted them to say
they said well uh you bought uh big dogs
sold this dope right here to you and you
know [__] like that he gave me something
to sell and [__] like that and he'll say
that's all he took he'll say to get us
off the street
everybody was in jail for something else
all they do they get on the bandwagon
and say well
I seen it with a gun in 94 and all
little type of [__] you know I mean
that's all it took yeah even though they
they ain't got the receiver with no guns
I can't go to every day when I was out
there
I never got busted with them
I mean but all they need is just he'll
sleep
so that's how you get off the hillside
that's all he took
but whatever
for the world Singleton issue
the case came out for Singleton and all
they need was he'll say
somebody got to say something that's all
they almost they even got to know you
they could just say
oh well yeah he had someone so so and
[__] like that that's all what you want
to do now man well now yeah you better
live
seeing how did everything else probably
been there and done that too
I'm just living now ain't nothing else
to do I can't get back out there because
too much going on
I'm six to five
but I still feel 37 though do you oh
[__] yeah
they could test me in a day
my dear Phil 37 yeah 12. I'm healthy
yeah
if you're a 29 yeah yeah
keep it real yeah that's the whole key
man with uh
everything that they went through
in the prison system and is to hopefully
may still still one of the youngsters
somewhere away from it once they watch
the podcast like man like
and understand that the system is just
as crooked as the dude you might be
standing next to but it's not the system
it
it's you
how you carry yourself while you're
innocence
I mean people say bless people you know
the ability for you
if you set your agenda to do this you
know you've got to stick to it don't let
anybody change it
I don't I don't I quit smoking I don't
I've been drinking you know [__] like
that I won't get in no trouble not that
I am scared of nobody
know I carry myself in prison though
yeah do what you're supposed to do and
just live your life I'll come on back
home we ain't going to prison to add on
they come eliminate
I got 30 years so I know I gotta do 26.
I'm trying to do that 26 come on back
home
my people out there the men are my
peoples in there
that's Federal you know it's just they
come from everywhere
he got from Haiti and all the places
they made a lot of my people my people
from Shreveport there you go well I'm
gonna try to make back home to my people
yeah all for me to do that I gotta stay
clean
you know band went through he went
through but we all different though we
didn't know everybody
got I had an attitude but I got I gotta
speaks that's what I got a lot of more
you got eight extra years yeah well he
got he was
told him that but you get the eight
extra years for stabbing up two dudes
that was stabbed the home boy and the
police were choking the dude in front of
me yeah and I beat him down drinking the
the police
already in handcuffs
you mind your own business man
but see what's interesting about that
band was telling me something about when
he went to court
he you say you found something in the in
in their stating that if somebody else
and then they have nothing to do with it
being a guard they said the court they
said that's in fplp policies state that
uh rights and responsibilities said that
you have the right protect yourself and
you have the right to also protect staff
or inmates that means you can use
necessary Force if a person's life is in
danger you believe that life is in
danger you can need necessary Force to
save that individual life and that's
what I did and that's what I fought for
that's why they knocked it out in two
years wow that's all facing 35. now
what's crazy is how you would have never
found it that never would have a dude
from DC called me two pack of cigarettes
he found it for me there got to be I
imagine you there's things in in all of
our lives that that we regret or things
that we think maybe we didn't do right
by but it seems to me that you you guys
keep coming back to this moral code like
you you're only going to do that because
somebody's crossing a line yeah yeah
that's what I'm endless would you would
you say that's right no it is even with
your mother coach your assignment is
going to protect you yeah your
assignment is done Simon may not be my
assignment Rich assignment may not be
his son call to assignment may not be
done Simon may be the hey tell the
youngster be quiet Carlos Simon maybe
tell the youngster be careful Richard
Simon maybe tell the youngster hey thank
my son maybe tell the youngster to hold
back a little bit so when we outside our
society if I'm worried about what
Richard doing and I'm worried about his
assignment and I'm not doing my
assignment did I cause a child Affair so
we all got to do what our assignment
says whatever we assigned to whatever we
are good at whatever we affect the
children at that's what we supposed to
do don't try to be everything for
everybody this is what we good at this
is Who We Are you know Don can't talk to
everybody like he talked to you can't
check everybody like he talked to us but
yet still his message get across clear
clear to us I can come down there
sometime and he can say hey man that
girl got shot and I don't like that
though I don't like that that mess with
my brain you don't have to tell me I go
make sure that don't happen no more
you know what I'm saying
so so this is his way of movement is
that's his assignment so we all got our
different assignment in every generation
every Legacy we got our different
assignment he came Carter okay use the
same assignment we use because some of
these dudes need a little more emphasis
on what you say to them
you see I'm saying opposed to what
Richard may say hey Bam cut that out
Cardinal man to pull up [__] look here
man there ain't gonna be no more of that
you see what I'm saying so but that's
his assignment
and and if I look at Carter and tell him
man you being too mean
I interfere with his assignment I get
caught or killed
you see what I'm saying so I don't even
feel we decide all I do is encourage him
and support him in his assignment even
if it ain't the same as mines
man we just want to own up something man
and and
continue doing something constructive
for that Community but till our time up
simple as that
you know what I'm saying we want the
money the power of the reasons
exactly exactly that's the side family
I appreciate the conversation you know
anything else you want to say now
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody I really
appreciate it if you dub what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
I hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself